así que está muy buenas noches pues ya
como lo comentaba alan con el 53% ya se
ha confirmado que yo no os va a ocupar a
la segundo el segundo escaño por georgia
en el senado de eeuu y de esta manera se
consigue la mayoría demócrata en la
cámara alta hasta hace pocos minutos
habían pocos simpatizantes de donald
trump que han querido venir hasta el
centro de la ciudad de atlanta donde se
encuentra el capitolio para dicen
expresar su rechazo a lo que han sido
unas elecciones fraudulentas y también
para mostrar su solidaridad con los
cientos de manifestantes que esta tarde
se han manifestado frente al congreso de
eeuu en washington dicen que ellos
tienen la responsabilidad de mostrar su
apoyo
sus compatriotas que hoy han expresado y
han participado de estos disturbios pero
si te parece hablamos de jong o soft que
también ha hecho historia porque va a
ser el senador más joven en ocupar una
silla en el senado de eeuu tiene 33 años
y también es el primer senador judío por
georgia que ha sido electo también otro
punto interesante de esta elección es
que desde el año 2000 no había
representación demócrata por georgia en
la cámara alta por eso aquí el partido
de joe biden está muy satisfechos con
los resultados dicen que ahora así con
el gobierno la cámara alta con la cámara
baja pues se podrán tramitar algunos de
esos proyectos de ley que había estado
hablando el entonces candidato
joe biden durante la campaña electoral
entre ellos
esta reforma migratoria para legalizar a
los millones de indocumentados que están
en eeuu pero también había planeaba la
amenaza de que el senado si iba a ser de
mayoría republicana pues podría llegar a
tumbar el obamacare dicen que ahora
respiran mucho más muchos más tranquilos
porque ahora va a estar todo con el
mismo color
antonio y que tanto empatan tanto la
ambiciosa agenda que tiene yo by dni lo
prometió durante la campaña presidencial
con estos dos senadores que han
resultado electos de su mismo partido
demócrata podrán llegar entonces con más
facilidad sobre todo a temas climáticos
que tuvieron en común ambas campañas
tanto de los senadores como de joe biden
resalta es alguna otra más
y aparte de eso esas políticas
climáticas que también el entonces
candidato había estado hablando durante
la campaña también medidas de seguridad
pero una de las más importantes son esos
paquetes o esas medidas económicas que
también yo vaivén va a tener que poner
sobre la mesa cuando llegue a la casa
blanca porque se vaticina una crisis
económica
bastante grave él ya ha dicho que tiene
sobre la mesa varias estrategias para
hacer frente a las consecuencias de esta
pandemia y entre ellos también serían
varias políticas económicas también para
incentivar el empleo para ayudar a los
pequeños negocios y de alguna manera
superar esta este escenario financiero
que va a acarrear va a acarrear
consecuencias gravísimas en el país y en
el resto del mundo